nachdem die bundesregierung in dieser
woche ja angekündigt hat und den weg
freigemacht hat für lieferung schwerer
waffen für lieferung von panzern aus
deutschen industrie beständen an die
ukraine haben heute die abgeordneten die
möglichkeit darüber zu diskutieren also
wie viel unterstützung wird es geben für
diesen schritt der bundesregierung der
durchaus eine zäsur war den weg für
schwere waffen für die ukraine
freizumachen von seiten der ampel quelle
der ampel fraktionen aber auch von
seiten der größten
oppositionsfraktion der cdu csu fraktion
und ich freue mich dass ich heute morgen
zwei gäste bei mir am set habe nämlich
zwei ausgewiesene experten für
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik
agnieszka bürger darf ich als begrüßen
für die grünen die stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende und johann wadephul
für die cdu/csu-fraktion der
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
ja wir wollen darauf schauen auf das
thema der waffenlieferung das thema ist
umstritten gewesen in den letzten wochen
tatsächlich jetzt hat die
bundesregierung den weg frei gemacht
es wird heute einen ungewöhnlichen
schulterschluss geben zwischen den
fraktionen die die ampel regierung
tragen und der größten
oppositionsfraktion der cdu csu fraktion
denn es gibt einen gemeinsamen antrag in
dem diese lieferung von schweren waffen
unterstützt werden soll wenn er denn
heute wie es sein soll mutmaßlich
abgestimmt wird und auch zugestimmt wird
frau becker wenn wir jetzt in diesen
antrag schauen und auf die linie schauen
die jetzt in zukunft für die nächsten
wochen gelten soll wie sieht die denn
aus wenn es um die lieferung von
schweren waffen an die ukraine geht sie
sieht so aus dass wir vor allem ein
instrument brauchen mit dem wir schnell
den einsatz von schweren waffen auch
ermöglichen können das ist der so
genannte ringtausch das heißt dass
partner aus alten beständen aus der
sowjetzeit gerät liefern panzer liefern
und wir sie dann bei den partnern mit
unserem material ersetzen und
gleichzeitig aber müssen auch jetzt vor
die vorbereitungen getroffen werden um
komplexere und modernere systeme auch
aus den beständen aus deutschland der
industrie oder möglicherweise der
bundeswehr auch auf den weg zu bringen
weil es eben ausbildung munition
ersatzteile wartungen braucht und
deshalb muss das zusammen im gleichklang
laufen und diese möglich er öffnet der
antrag der wahl obwohl eigentlich hatte
die unionsfraktion einen wesentlichen
weitergehenden antrag sie haben
tatsächlich auch gefordert dass man aus
den beständen der bundeswehr auch
kampfpanzer beispielsweise schicken
sollte und größtmögliche unterstützung
an rüstungsgütern der ukraine liefern
sollte jetzt haben sie diesen antrag
zurückgezogen haben sich dem der ampel
angeschlossen warum weil das
kernanliegen erfüllt wird und zwar im
wort das heißt im beschluss heute aber
auch im praktischen tun es ist richtig
an den ringtausch zu machen es ist
richtig die ukrainische armee zunächst
mit dem gerät auszustatten was sie kennt
das ist altes sowjetisches
material das ist gut das ist richtig es
ist darüber hinaus richtig weiteres
deutsches material zu liefern wie die
radpanzer der wird nicht sofort
verfügbar sein aber der wird später die
ukraine auch unterstützen können und
genau das beschließen wir jetzt im
deutschen bundestag das war ja eine
schwere geburt man hat gemerkt die ampel
koalition hat sich dabei sehr schwer
getan gab gewichtige stimmen dafür die
fdp hat es beschlossen wichtige stimme
auch bei den grünen waren frühzeitig
dafür der bundeskanzler hat sich sehr
schwergetan
das war bedauerlich aber wenn am ende
wie eine einigung haben dann ist es
unsere politik als cdu/csu
außenpolitisch hier auf gemeinsamkeit zu
setzen damit die deutsche politik im
europäischen konzert geschlossen
wahrgenommen wird
etwas erstaunlich den ringtausch
beispielsweise da kommen wir gleich noch
mal zu den haben sie selbst in der
letzten woche noch eher abgelehnten
haben gesagt das ist eigentlich nicht
genug also was hat sich denn geändert
nein ja genau ich habe gesagt es ist
nicht genug es ist nicht genug aber es
wird jetzt noch mehr gemacht der gebhard
ist ja dazu gekommen und das ist ein
komplexes aber ein sehr gutes deutsches
waffensystem was zusätzlich jetzt
geliefert wird der ringtausch allein
macht es nicht der ist gut er ist
richtig die bundesregierung hat sich
schrittweise nach vorne bewegt aber in
die richtige richtung und dann wollen
wir auch nicht besserwisserisch sein
sondern es ist einfach wichtig dass wir
in zentralen fragen in der
demokratischen mitte des hauses wir
haben an den beiden ländern
schon sehr viel extreme position dass
wir danach zusammen steht frau becker
der ringtausch sie haben es angesprochen
steht im antrag drin die bundesregierung
hat es auch schon angekündigt wird auch
schon gemacht nato-partner slowenien in
dem fall das ist schon geplant der
nato-partner slowenien gibt der ukraine
panzer von sowjetischer bauart und
deutschland liefert slowenien sozusagen
dann panzer nach um die bestände
aufzufüllen sozusagen genau warum kann
man denn so wie in den panzer liefern
aber der ukraine nicht direkt es ist
auch gar kein gegeneinander sondern es
geht wirklich um die zeitliche abfolge
und ist es wichtig dass beide maßnahmen
im zusammenhang gesehen werden weil die
entscheidungen modernere und komplexere
systeme zu liefern einfach voraussetzung
es voll ist denn es muss ausbildung
sichergestellt sein die lieferung von
munition auch die frage ersatzteile und
wartung wir sehen wirklich mutige
ukrainische streitkräfte die
beachtliches geleistet haben in den
letzten wochen aber jetzt wenn man
möchte dass schweres gerät ganz
unmittelbar sehr schnell zum einsatz
kommt ist der ringtausch das richtige
instrument aber es gibt ja auch in dem
antrag und auch in den entscheidungen
der bundesregierung die klare
bereitschaft auch selbst schweres gerät
aus deutschland zuliefern ja aber das
wars jetzt angekündigt wurde in dieser
woche die zäsur dass diese gepard panzer
alte bestände der bundeswehr die von
einem rüstungsunternehmen die dort in
den beständen sind weitergegeben werden
können da soll jetzt die ausfuhr
genehmigt werden aber wenn sie sagen die
ausbildung muss gewährleistet sein auf
diesem system da gibt es jetzt kritik
ist dieser gepard panzer überhaupt das
richtige um die ukraine jetzt schnell zu
unterstützen weil die ausbildung dauert
beispielsweise unheimlich lang also ist
das das richtige gerät oder ist es mehr
symbolpolitik dass man jetzt was
freigeben wollte nein es ist auf jeden
fall das richtige gerät aber wenn man
nur den gebhard tanzer jetzt genehmigt
hätte dann hätte man unmittelbar für die
nächsten monate nichts anzubieten was
den menschen jetzt in dem kampf den sie
ja täglich führen um ihr leben ihre
freiheit ihre sicherheit etwas
anzubieten und sie dabei zu unterstützen
und deshalb müssen diese maßnahme im
gleichklang laufen und so auch in der
zeitlichen abfolge stopfen erwarten sie
haben gestern die bundesministerin hier
im bundestag selbst noch nach diesem
gebhard panzern gefragt und waren
durchaus skeptisch ob das so das
richtige gerät ist jetzt sagen sie doch
eigentlich ein richtiger schritt
versteht nicht weil es ein großer
schritt für die bundesregierung ist sie
hat das ja vorher abgelehnt jedenfalls
der bundeskanzler hat es abgelehnt so
etwas zu machen und ich will einfach
würdigen und ich finde es einfach auch
richtig dass der schritt jetzt getan
wird dass wir deutsches gerät einen
deutschen panzer liefern ich will jetzt
nicht auf die idee gekommen den gebhard
als erstes zu nehmen weil er das
komplexeste waffensystem ist ich kenne
den recht gut weil ich in der
truppengattung gedient habe da braucht
man mindestens ein halbes jahr warum die
soldaten daran auszubilden damit der
sinnvoll eingesetzt werden kann ich
hätte er den maler geliefert das ist ein
schützenpanzer der hier auch zur
verfügung steht oder den leopard 1 der
ist noch etwas komplizierter aber auch
noch einfacher zu bedienen als der
gepard ich will jetzt wirklich mal in
den vordergrund stellen die
bundesregierung hat sich hier bewegt und
sie hat ja auch zugesagt mehr zu tun es
ist hat eine konferenz mit den usa
gegeben in ramstein vorgestern wo man
zugesagt habe jetzt monatlich sich zu
treffen und zu schauen was kann man mehr
tun und wenn wir jetzt sehen ist wird
der ringtausch gemacht das heißt es wird
sowjetisches material geliefert was die
sofort bedienen können dann stelle ich
mir vor dass man schaut ob man nicht
noch weiteres material hat was einfacher
zu bedienen ist als der gibb hat in der
zwischenzeit liefern kann und später
kann dann auch der gepard unterstützen
wir müssen uns leider darauf einstellen
keiner weiß das dass dieser krieg länger
dauert das ist eine befürchtung die wir
haben müssen und ich glaube es ist auch
ein signal an putin zu zeigen dass wir
uns auf einen längeren konflikt
einstellen und nicht morgen oder
übermorgen die unterstützung der ukraine
beenden sondern dass wir auch gewillt
sind das länger zu führen immer
natürlich mit dem ziel möglichst schnell
möglichst wirklich am liebsten morgen zu
einem ende dieses krieges zu kommen
huber ja die ukraine müsste vielleicht
noch länger unterstützt werden
werden jetzt heute mit diesem antrag
auch eine große unterstützung aus den
reihen des bundestages für die
bundesregierung kommt wo sind eigentlich
die grenzen mit was wir die ukraine an
waffen ausrüsten und ausrüsten wollen es
ist erstmal wichtig dass diese starke
zeichen der solidarität von der so
großen mehrheit des deutschen
parlamentes kommt dass die unterstützung
für die ukraine ebenso immens und so
stark ist und auch in deutschland so
breit getragen wird aber natürlich fragt
sich jeder von uns was können wir noch
mehr tun jeden tag und gleichzeitig
haben wir natürlich auch alle eine
verantwortung und es ist eine linie
beschrieben war wurden in den letzten
wochen die auch bereit als konsens in
diesem hohen hause gilt auch von der
bundesregierung geschrieben worden dass
man eben nicht direkt in das
militärische geschehen eingreift dass
man nicht direkt zur konfliktpartei wird
weil dann damit natürlich extreme
risiken verboten verbunden sind umso
mehr muss man alles andere tun was man
tun kann wo sind die grenzen darauf
wollte ich auch so ein bisschen hinaus
wo sind die grenzen dessen was
deutschland liefern kann und eine
unterstützung leisten kann weil
beispielsweise bestände der bundeswehr
haben wir jetzt mehrfach gehört von der
verteidigungsministerin auch vom kanzler
sind leer oder also die
möglichkeiten aus den beständen der
bundeswehr zu liefern sind in der tat
schon sehr weit ausgeschöpft aber umso
mehr muss man dann eben schauen was auch
mit blick auf die industrie auf altes
gerät der bundeswehr was bei der
industrie steht auch möglich ist dass
müssen immer wieder viele komplexe
fragen
behandelt werden und auch mit
internationalen partnern besprochen
werden das beispiel der panzerhaubitze
in kooperation mit den niederlanden wo
gerät von dort möglicherweise geliefert
wird und deutschland sich dann um die
ausbildung kümmert das sind natürlich
fragen müssen geklärt werden bevor sie
etwas verkündet werden kann aber daran
arbeitet die bundesregierung tag für tag
der wade pohlig hatte bei der union in
den letzten zwei wochen ein bisschen den
eindruck dass hier nicht ganz glauben
dass man aus den beständen der
bundeswehr nichts mehr liefern kann also
sehen sie da ist da vielleicht doch noch
ein unterschied sehen sie da
möglichkeiten durchaus mehr zu liefern
und nicht einigt sich darauf zurück zu
ziehen wir brauchen das für die eigene
bündnis und landesverteidigung ja in der
tat würde ich sagen also ich glaube wir
müssen einfach lernen
auch ein bisschen selbstkritisch dass
sachen auszuschließen nicht klug ist wir
sind ja immer neue schritte gegangen die
wir vor zwei wochen noch nicht für
möglich gehalten haben was ging für die
lieferung von waffen überhaupt von
schweren waffen jetzt erst recht und
auch für die lieferung von waffen aus
beständen der bundeswehr natürlich ist
die bundeswehr sehr knapp ausgestattet
auch unter ausgestattet was ist ja
unstreitig deswegen wollen wir sie ja
auch stärker ausstatten und reden über
100 milliarden sondervermögen das
vollkommen klar aber die wir sind ja
jetzt nicht in der situation zum glück
und das soll ja auch nicht der fall
werden dass deutschland und das
bündnisgebiet direkt bedroht ist das
heißt ich würde die frage ob jetzt ich
nenne ein beispiel 40 marder bei der
bundeswehr vorhanden sind oder
vielleicht jetzt der ukraine zur
verfügung gestellt werden mindestens mal
offen lassen ich finde wir müssen jede
option jetzt
auch prüfen denn am ende ist es so die
freiheit und die sicherheit auch
deutschlands ganz europas wird jetzt in
der ukraine verteidigt das muss man
sehen wenn dieser krieg nicht gestoppt
wird dann wird er weiter gehen russland
hat schon klar kriegsziele formuliert
die auf moldau abzielen das heißt immer
näher an das gebiet auch der nato
herankommen der nächste start ist dann
rumänien das ist nato gebiet und
deswegen je früher wir putin ein klares
stopp signal senden umso besser
ich möchte noch mit ihnen auf einer
weiteren punkt in diesem antrag gucken
der insgesamt 40 forderungen an die
bundesregierung gerichtet wir werden
dazu ja dann gleich noch in der debatte
etwas hören aber das knüpft daran an was
sie habe gesagt haben im antrag steht
nämlich auch neben der unterstützung der
ukraine verbindet uns das gemeinsame
ziel zu verhindern dass russland den
krieg auf weitere staaten ausdehnt im
russischen staatsfernsehen wird ja schon
offen darüber gesprochen beispielsweise
die bundesregierung wird aufgefordert
den ausbau der truppenpräsenz der nato
an ihrer ostflanke durch weitere
soldatinnen und soldaten der bundeswehr
zu unterstützen was kommt da noch auf
die bundeswehr auf deutschland zu
dass wir auch mit einer stärkeren
präsenz und das ist ja auch direkt seit
kriegsbeginn geschehen auch gerade bei
unseren baltischen partnern vor ort sind
auch mit blick auf den südosten des
bündnisgebietes verstärken das kann sich
im luftraum überwachung halten das kann
um die stationierung von truppen gehen
das sind alles fragen die derzeit in der
nato diskutiert werden aber wir spüren
natürlich dass die sorgen und ängste die
unsere ost und mitteleuropäischen
partnerinnen und partner seit jahren
hatten sehr real waren und dass wir dort
hätten besser zuhören müssen und deshalb
war auch die reise der bundes
außenministerin ins baltikum mit den
entsprechenden zusagen ein sehr sehr
wichtiges zeichen dass wir
zusammenstehen und da kein zweifel daran
aufkommen kann die aussenministerin war
in den baltischen staaten in litauen
beispielsweise sind 1500 soldaten
stationiert 1000 davon von der
bundeswehr
wie viel kann die bundeswehr überhaupt
leisten wie sie derzeit dasteht und was
sie derzeit noch an sonstigen aufgaben
eher leisten muss ich glaube die
bundeswehr kann die
bündnisverpflichtungen vollständig
erfüllen das ist
anstrengend das nimmt viele kapazitäten
in anspruch aber es gelingt es auch
wichtig dass wir diese signale senden
ich finde es sehr gut und war sehr
wichtig dass die außenministerin da war
weil natürlich gerade im baltikum sehr
genau geschaut wird ob deutschland an
der seite dieser länder steht ich meine
da gibt's denn traumatische erfahrung
aus dem letzten jahrhundert als
schrecklicher weise hitler mit stalin
pakt geschlossen hat und deutschland auf
dem rücken dieser länder nicht nur
politik gemacht hat sondern auch ein
krieg geführt hat deswegen haben wir
eine besondere verantwortung die nehmen
wir wahr aber vollkommen klar ist die
bundeswehr muss besser ausgestattet
werden deswegen haben wir darüber
gestern hier diskutiert da wird auch den
schulterschluss wieder der
demokratischen mitte glaube ich am ende
geben wir müssen für die bundeswehr mehr
tun wir müssen für die
verteidigungsfähigkeit europas mehr tun
und wir können uns das ist ja auch die
lehre der letzten jahre nicht immer
darauf verlassen dass es so ist wie
jetzt dass die amerikaner sich so stark
engagieren das heißt wir sind ein stück
weit auf uns selber mehr gestellt den
antrag der heute beschlossen werden soll
der hat keine sozusagen
gesetz gesetzliche wirkung also erst
nicht gesetz binden für die
bundesregierung trotzdem wird es
natürlich ein starkes signal sein ihr
fraktionsvorsitzender friedrich merz hat
gestern gesagt keiner tut es sich macht
es sich ja leicht mit der lieferung an
schweren waffen ist das vielleicht in
der diskussion ein bisschen kurz
gekommen frau brucker ja also eine
diskussion der letzten tage ist vor
allem auch der punkt zu kurz gekommen
warum es diese waffenlieferungen geben
muss die sanktionen waren richtig und
sie sind hart aber sie haben nicht dazu
geführt dass dieser krieg unmittelbar
gestoppt wird das einzige was die
russischen truppen bisher aufgehalten
hat das einzige was zur befreiung von
besetzten gebieten in denen massivste
menschenrechtsverletzungen verübt worden
sind beigetragen hat das war der mutige
widerstand der ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer und diesen müssen wir
unterstützen und deshalb haben wir uns
diese entscheidung nicht leicht gemacht
aber deshalb ist sie am ende des tages
auch richtig weil wir sonst unmittelbar
diesen brutalen krieg kalkül nichts
entgegen setzen würden vielen dank in
beiden wir müssen rein gehen wir werden
sie in der debatte auch hören herr
wadephul für die cdu/csu-fraktion und
frau broker für die grünen vielen dank